all right turn around her rate 105
got it 105 Oh mother [ __ ] Oh
[Music]
what's up Peter
yeah I'm proofing it right now
I'll have a team 5 minutes a killer
hangover in a 2,000 word article I was
screwed but then I remembered that
little mind-altering device a company
had sent me to review I had no idea if
it would work but how much worse could
this day get I was blind but now I see
information from a TED talk someone told
me about a half read blog post a Netflix
documentary I'd slept through it was all
bubbling up in my right temple mixing
itself into an artisan cocktail of
useful information what was this device
I wasn't high he wasn't wired just clear
I knew what I needed to write and how to
write it I felt limitless and said hey
guys I'm Brent rose tech writer and
dilettante cyborg today for GQ we're
gonna be talking about think this little
device that sticks to your face pairs
with your phone and can help you master
your mood supposedly let's hear what the
company has to say about it so it's
using your nerves in the same way that
used normally right below your skin
nerves in your face and they can keep
directing you it's not gonna give me
brain cancer or make my brain
radioactive or anything like that's
right
cool so this is a golf strip and now we
go to the comen you the app recognizes
the type of strip there are two types
then you put this on choose your body
okay so that sounds good in theory but
how does it actually work in practice
I've devised four tests to simulate your
average everyday experience we're
talking waking up hungover going
go-karting being electrocuted and then
going on a hot date let's see how this
thing holds up under stress
we've given me an honest-to-goodness
hangover my head is bumping
I feel like garbage we're going to do a
couple typing speed tests to see how my
brain is doing here we go baseline test
okay so that was a pretty good baseline
will see if I do any better on the redo
so boost mode they said is like the jolt
it's possible that psychosomatic can
sting a little bit but it definitely
feels like um Wow maybe it's because my
face is being electrocuted but I do feel
a little bit more awake let's do this
yeah
well okay typing speed 80 point to
accuracy 99 and test number three of
three here we go
all right so I just finished the third
test but in the middle of the the three
tests it seems about right to me I feel
good I feel slightly less hungover
I could still deal with an aspirin let's
move on to the Ricky Bobby test I want
to go fast
we're at k1 speed in South San Francisco
we're going to do our first few laps
without the think device just to set a
baseline and then we'll plug me in turn
me on and see what happens
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna use the go mode this time
because because I'm gonna go just camp
it all the way up to
how do you feel I feel good I may have
turned it up a little bit too high my my
ear is tingling and I feel like is it
twitching a little bit
you
[Music]
I'm the house fast that really was felt
fast so it turns out these results were
a little more compelling than we
originally thought I shaved three
seconds off my three lap time and a full
second and a half of my best lap now
that said obviously as I was doing the
course more and more I was getting more
comfortable with it so it makes sense
that my times would go down it
definitely gave me a more aggressive
feeling while driving which makes me
think maybe you shouldn't use go mode
while driving down the highway anyway
let's see how some these calm modes work
my producer Peter is going to flip a
coin if its tail's I get a free pass if
it's heads however I get the working end
of the flashlight we've got a chest
strap heart rate monitor on me and it's
paired to this watch I've been cruising
right around 100 105 beats per minute
right now so that's kind of a good
baseline I'll just be happy if I don't
piss my pants all right happy with this
all right
103 all right looking the coin got it
all right 102 103 104 oh uh it's still
at 103
all right Karev huh heart rate just went
out 105 105 Oh mother [ __ ] oh I'm at
one for 1415 what 16 awesome a bit 120
better if I hurt 20 good okay I'm gonna
try to get back to baseline we're gonna
see how fast I can do that so now we're
going to put the think this is one of
the calming strips attach the back of
the neck right there
get that so let's start the vibe what do
we want maybe ease eases what I want
here right now go nice and easy you guys
or the think team just checking in to
make sure that demo device is being used
in the way it was intended yep no
problem
got the nice tingle and the temple on
the back of my neck heart rates about a
hundred hundred one so let's play this
horrible little game again
stupid stupid gang think you came up
with okay 98 99 100 9 110 Oh Maron so
mad Oh
119 120 ah okay all right back to 120
gonna see how fast and get back to
baseline so that's pretty interesting it
only took about half the time to get
back to baseline as it did before I
definitely feel a lot calmer than I did
and it felt like I could just go
straight into the the breathing and
really relaxing so maybe it's placebo
effect but it worked for our next test
we're going to put me in a very common
stressful situation first date I matched
with a girl on a certain dating app
let's just say it rhymes with SH Mandir
she's cute she's fit and I warned her
there would be cameras there'd be weird
things on my head she agreed
I'm legitimate little nervous about this
let's see if these vibes can calm me
down
my heart rate just spiked to 120 -
higher than it was when I got
electrocuted so this thing isn't doing
anything let's go hi how are you all
coming to the most awkward first date
there I'm going with whisky on the rocks
it sounded like a really good idea my
major concern is like I'll like you for
who you are and then he'll get cancer
she's afraid she's gonna fall in love
with me and I'll get brain cancer and be
like one of the great tragedies of her
life thank you very much mister McNiven
you have a wonderful establishment here
oh we just met my god what are your
tattoos uh antimony it's Mont Blanc
which is the race I want to do
eventually in my life should we have a
think day straight out of my sci-fi
fantasy kick this date into high gear
so we're gonna with the alert one maybe
but they say that's a good one to start
with this is your first time on be
gentle nice and caring soft touch oh wow
thanks so much my dear sir one yeah
three thank you for giving my date and
bowl here this is date debating the
stage
I actually feel less awkward now I mean
cute heart rate is 95 I'm doing the
energized one of my heart rates going
down I have never done a date on camera
naked and afraid I don't know I have
always to be good hey sexy
see ya the back of your mind I could see
it there seems really cool
I'm he's cute initially very hero and
very kind which I like a lot feel like
you'd be more caring if this was not
happening yeah these are good thing
I mean look at me I can't imagine
attractive device on my forehead maybe
like in 2020 the dates going okay she's
very nice funny sarcastic cute feel like
maybe if I did this before a date
you got like into nice calms and place
then took it off yeah then maybe I could
see some benefits from it as far as
vibing together as a couple we've not
been able to read each other's thoughts
at all that's pretty disappointing
letting you know that I've officially
turned you on only electronic man oh
that was a sick burn
here we go up to a hundred out Ellie out
90 [ __ ] oh she's biting me Oh hundred
sucks don't ever go to plaster Cheers
painful experiences my dad I mean this
entire village I hated this ah so what
did we learn here today think is a
pretty interesting device it helped me
fire up go-kart racing and it helped me
calm down after being electrocuted it
didn't really seem to help so much on
the date but then again it was making me
more nervous because I felt like [ __ ]
idiot wearing it during a day let us
know what you think in the comments
below subscribe if you haven't already
if you haven't seen my videos on wired
check them out below with all that being
said there's only one thing left to do
oh god Christina would you help me hmm
sexy time [ __ ] all right cool
apparently works pretty well in the
first date oh yeah oh yeah so Bernie I'm
so calm and so relaxed at the same time
oh my god
oh yeah like you're twitching neck
burning